we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p let's listen
to this interesting voicemail together
yeah your podcast show and all that your
big joke yeah yeah right you go back to
Argentina and stay there yeah well
there's a few reasons why I mean mostly
that I live here now I guess is the
reason you're under no obligation to
listen to the podcast it's always
interesting when people are so put off
by what we're doing yet they insist on
listening or watching there's many other
things to watch that you're under know
what you're not strapped into headphones
and you have to listen to the David
Pakman show check out something else on
the bonus show today did we watch the
inauguration how much of it did we watch
what did we hear about it from friends
we'll talk about that and more also we
have a very controversial interview
upcoming and I want to talk about that
with you and there's also a whole other
set of anti-trump marches and rallies
planned and i'll tell you all about it
on the bonus show david pakman.com slash
membership that's the one place to sign
up for membership you get instant access
to all of the member benefits including
but not limited to the exclusive
members-only bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show we are viewer and listener
supported media help us to continue
doing what we do by signing up at david
pakman.com slash membership if normal
pricing is high use the coupon code I
voted 17 I don't need you to pay full
price if full price is a burden to you I
just want you involved at whatever level
is comfortable so you can use coupon
code I voted 17 and get a big discount
all right we'll talk to you on the bonus
show